it is 11 a.m. on a Sunday in the San
Francisco Bay Area and I am headed to
brunch
it's an unusual scene for me because
where I grew up the type of dedication
I'm showing to eggs was reserved for
this
[Music]
Church where the enthusiasm comes from
food for the Soul and not the stomach
today fewer people in the United States
are keeping the faith Protestants no
longer make up the majority of US adults
yet discussions about evangelicals
seemingly dominate the political
landscape we're going to protect
Christianity the right to keep and bear
arms it's not bestowed by man but
granted by God and Christians
overwhelmingly made up the majority of
Congress in 2016 so how does this
national focus on Christians affect
their perceptions their politics their
beliefs and the nation so I believe that
many people believe evangelicals are
part of a political party rather than a
subset of the Christian faith the word
evangelical is sort of been hijacked and
has become to be known as more of a
right-wing
purist type of political term hey fam I
me Mayan this is AG plus and this Sunday
we've traveled in hopes of finding out
what it really means to be an
evangelical and whether faith and
politics should be interwove in'
only 6% of adults in the US are
evangelicals and yet the candidates and
the news media were obsessed with them
and they still are how much support do
you think Trump actually has within the
evangelical community bless the great
state of Florida it's revenge of white
America it is revenge of evangelical
right-wingers and I noticed a curious
thing whenever I would hear the word
evangelical it was almost always
synonymous with white Christians and a
series of campaign controversies didn't
stop him from winning 81% of the white
evangelical vote this overwhelmingly
white depiction of evangelicals is
vastly different from what I had known
growing up as a kid in the south these
images made me question the actual
definition of evangelical and who gets
to be one
are they evangelical or them to be
evangelical means different things to
different people and that's part of the
reason why it's so difficult to define
the term to get a better understanding
of the term evangelical and the people
who identify as such I visited one of
the most Bible minded cities in America
Houston Texas
that's where I met Avis Blake Thomas
evangelical Christian really is - in my
opinion about the basic doctrines the
basic beliefs the core beliefs of
Christianity evangelical Christian to me
is a little bit of redundancy because
every Christian knows that one of the
key components of being a Christian is
to spread the good news to spread the
gospel of Jesus Christ
Blake Thomas is a pastor and co-founded
the open Bible Academy a nonprofit
organization that gives free theological
biblical training she says she's seen
the word evangelical being co-opted you
have people that identify as evangelical
but don't share evangelical belief I am
an evangelical but not from a political
viewpoint I'm an evangelical from the
basic understanding of what it means for
the Christian faith
she believes many of the people
identified as evangelicals are totally
unfamiliar with the Bible the tenants of
the Christian faith and the history of
evangelism in most cases Christians in
America particularly today
don't have a good understanding of the
Bible so they don't know what they
believe they don't understand that it's
more than going to a two-hour service on
Sunday the evangelical movement began as
a populist revolt in the 18th and 19th
centuries it was anti intellectual and
anti elitist and it was often spread by
untutored preachers who used common
storytelling to spread their message and
then a little quirky decade called the
1980s happened the 80s are when a former
actor named Ronald Reagan who was
divorced and rarely attended church
watches an alliance between the
Republican Party and religious leaders
emerged one that helped him win the
White House it was a political act by
the political right which created the
religious right it was politically
created for the sake of the Republican
Party Christian writer in evangelical
Jim Wallace says the GOP plan was a
concerted effort literally there were
operatives political operatives from the
right who came to mega church pastors
and said I'll make you a household word
give me your list and that's how they
created the religious right sune faces
like this one became one of those
associated with the religious right
that's conservative activist Jerry
Falwell and along with the political
action group called the moral majority
he pushed for a more conservative
religious agenda the moral majority
mobilized conservative Christians and
politics Wallace says fall was politics
and interpretation of the faith
represented a major change in how
evangelicals were seen before Falwell
people like evangelist Billy Graham were
the face and the voice of mainstream
Christianity in the United States do you
love God do you love him with all your
heart with all your soul with all your
mind and by Wallace's definition this
guy is also an evangelical King spoke
frankly about the racial divisions
within the American Christian Church and
actually this obelisk behind me is
dedicated to his memory outside a modern
chapel in Houston Texas I think it is
one of the
of our nation one of the shameful
tragedies at 11 o'clock on Sunday
morning is one of the most segregated
hours not the most segregated hours in
Christian America 50 years after King's
assassination the exact same problem
still plagues the American Christian
Church racial division
according to Wallace and we saw that
firsthand in the aftermath of the 2016
election cycle when the vast majority of
white evangelicals voted for Donald
Trump but the majority of evangelicals
of color didn't even Jellico's if
they're going to be really evangelical
should name and denounce racism as a sin
from their pulpits how many white
churches have done that pastor icky
stoma says part of what keeps the church
divided is the variation and how black
and white parishioners see the world for
many white evangelical Christians and
black evangelical Christians the way
that they view the world is different
even though they read the same Bible and
trust the same Jesus the lenses that we
study the Bible through this colored by
our culture soma is a Japanese born US
citizen who grew up attending mostly
white churches and was naturalized 15
years ago he doesn't identify as either
a Republican or a Democrat but says he's
seen how politics is intersected with
religion in fact when you hear the term
evangelical you're probably more likely
to see it presented this way Jesus
himself gave us the flu shot a person
for their Christian convictions is going
to be put in jail because they refuse to
bow to a decision that is suspect at
best you're gonna be held seriously
seriously to account by God if you don't
vote the word evangelical has a
different meaning in the United States
than it does internationally according
to Wallace and he says that's because
the u.s. there's a poor job of
representing people of color in general
in fact they're more than 2 billion
Christians worldwide according to Pew
that's about a third of the global
population and Christians are so
widespread that no one region can claim
to be the center of global Christianity
about 26% of Christians live in Europe
37% in the
Americas and sub-saharan Africa is home
to 24% of the population for Wallace
being a Christian means a commitment to
the Bible Jesus
and the poor America first for example
is a heresy son America first
it's Jesus first but if our gospel isn't
good news to the poor it is not the
gospel of Jesus Christ period and white
evangelicals in America are not known to
have a gospel that is good news the
Bible also has 2,000 verses about the
poor compared to just 12 on
homosexuality according to Wallace but
you've probably heard much more about
those verses on homosexuality in news
coverage we're talking about marriage
we're talking about an institution that
has survived and served this
civilization for over 5,000 years with
one definition you are never going to
stop until you stop treating homosexual
sodomy as a civil right and start
treating it as do these types of
depictions really mean that the news
media doesn't understand religion
wallace thinks so and he says that the
news media's betrayal of faith is a big
part of the problem media who are not
very faith friendly like to paint
Christians in the worst possible way and
so if you make religious Rite synonymous
with Christian or evangelical sometimes
with white evangelical that makes
Christians limpid if the media does have
a religious literacy problem it's not
alone Americans don't know much about
religion Pew Research says that those
most likely to be knowledgeable about
religion in the u.s. have an advanced
college degree this lack of
understanding may explain the public's
perception a perception that makes it
much more difficult for self-identified
Christians according to Blake Thomas
those of us who are true evangelicals
get a bad rap because they see the an
evangelical term used in the political
sphere the challenge is that in the
marketplace when people hear the term
evangelical and they then see how those
same people their values may not match
or their understanding does not seem to
match ours she says she believes
just one reason why the Christian faith
is on the decline in the u.s. when you
have people that just simply identify
with it from a political standpoint they
don't bring to the table those same sets
of beliefs they they see it as political
expediency versus a belief system versus
a part of religion so how do
evangelicals go about fixing what seems
to be a public relations problem well
the first thing can be realizing that
faith doesn't have a political party we
shouldn't be religious right or
religious left I don't take that on
either we should be Christians it's
Jesus first and just because you're
evangelical it doesn't mean that you
don't struggle with understanding issues
of identity race gender and sex the
Christian can still struggle with sins
like racism prejudice and things like
that so I would say the place that the
church has in politics is encouraged
their members to be upright citizens
either with Christian or not and we will
be known by our fruit that we bear hey
fam thanks so much for watching don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and I
want to know whether you think
evangelicals are accurately represented
in news media let us know and don't
forget to come back next week when we
have another awesome video bye